You go down to San Diego and what,
what are they doing for you that gets you off of the antidepressants and gets
you feeling better?
So,
uh,
it's again,
like you get in there and I mean it's,
it's scary to go.
Again,
like I said,
there's,
there's all these different people in there.
I'm the man found the,
the research on it by treating his own autistic kid and you can see the before
and after videos of this kid and it's like,
damn.
Okay.
And then,
um,
I brought my son into,
cause he has ADHD and he's off his medication now as well.
So I'm going in there.
Uh,
they do an EEG first and then they can tell which parts of your brain are firing
it,
what hurts in seeing,
um,
the congruencies in like how all of that is happening or not happening.
And um,
then they kind of prescribed these,
these different,
these machines like on your,
on your brain that make,
uh,
these like electric impulses,
but they're magnetic to,
um,
kind of speed up or slow down the different parts of your brain.
So if the front of your brain is moving slower than the back of your brain are
those or,
or whatever.
So,
um,
they're noticing obviously,
uh,
patterns with fighters,
hockey players,
football players,
like,
like people that are leading with their heads.
Basically.
I'm having like,
uh,
and then with the veterans are like emotional things to where I mean ever.
And Yeah.
And then like,
I mean,
having to compartmentalize as well,
like some of the shit they see should be upsetting,
you know,
and,
and you know,
but there's,
there's different ways that we can train our brain to,
to drop things like that.
And then PTSD is when it's an involuntary and it all comes in and,
and that,
so,
you know,
I,
I've been diagnosed with PTSD.
I had walked in there with medication because of being depressed,
uh,
and the anxiety and all of that.
Like my symptoms were terrible.
And I know there are a combination of things,
but even like my startle reflex,
like,
you know,
I could hear someone come walking around the corner like,
clap,
clap here,
their shoes.
But the second I'd see them,
it would,
it would stop my heart for a second.
And that's like shit on your adrenal glands,
you know,
and,
um,
all this stuff was anxiety that,
I don't know.
It was,
it was hard to fall asleep at night.
Uh,
you know,
my memory was crap and this is all,
different stuff happening in all these other fighters that I know as well.
But I mean,
like I said,
I've been trying things so much,
so much over the past few years that I get excited about and either it works or
it doesn't.
And,
um,
the,
the point is,
is,
is now I found this and I feel better from this,
but I,
I was so excited about all these other things.
Like I can't just start telling everybody of the new thing that I found because
I've said that and been excited about like everything else with this one,
this one,
like the equal scope,
it's like,
uh,
it's,
um,
same thing.
It's kind of like a tens machine or stem machine,
but like a super,
super low frequency.
And that's bad ass too.
I get it.
It helped on injuries,
like if I rolled my ankle or hurt my toe,
like you could bring the swelling down from this to to normal essentially in
like an hour and a half just working on with this like tens unit on it.
And,
and I mean they originally used it for race horses and for you know,
super expensive million dollar horses.
Like the equipment they brought over,
it was like 90 grand and like,
like these really specific like special metals that were put into these plates
and you know,
they do stuff like that,
but that wasn't working on my head.
It was working on injuries and it was working on,
um,
I want to say it helped with like my like digestive system maybe or my,
uh,
I don't remember some,
some other things it was helping with too,
but what,
you know,
I,
I I started doing that,
um,
or I was doing that when I walked into mindset and started doing that treatment.
So you sit in a chair,
you know,
and they ha they put this prescription in this machine and the machine is kinda
got like a,
like a arm that goes on in a specific part of your brain and you,
you know,
you close your eyes and it sends these,
these magnetic pulses into your head.
And I mean,
you don't feel anything.
It's almost like you can hear what it feels like,
but I don't know how to describe it.
It's,
it's a sense it's,
there's,
it's central but it's not,
it's not exactly hearing and it's not exactly feeling,
um,
yeah.
And I mean you,
you leave the place after your treatment.
Like I go,
I would go twice a day.
It's 45 minutes away both ways.
So I am driving a lot everyday to go to do this cause I want to give it a fair
shot,
do it every day.
I do everyday,
I haven't gone these past couple of weeks cause uh,
stuff with my kids.
Uh,
scheduled school's almost out and then wanting to try out different things with
different coaches as far as these new disciplines go.
So I haven't been there as much.
But um,
yeah,
for the last August I believe is is when I was like really,
really getting into it and go on twice a day and 45 minutes each way.
Twice a day.
Yeah.
You would spend 45 minutes one way,
go back,
go back again.
Just fucking move closer to where the places,
because the alliance was down there and so I would,
I would drop my kid off at school.
I would run,
and then I would go there.
I would do my treatment,
I'd go back to practice down in southern San Diego,
then I'd get my son,
and then we'd go up there for the afternoon session and then I'd come back down
and,
and we'd go to his sports and then I'd have my second two a day.
That does not leave a lot of free time for cats and Ghana.
Oh Hell No.
Just that alone can be stressful.
But I was seeing the results.
That was the crazy thing is I was feeling better.
Well,
the results when I just walked
in,
like,
like God,
like I couldn't sleep,
I had just,
uh,
anxiety,
like I had that,
that um,
startle effect going,
like the,
um,
my memory was shit and these were all things that I went to the UFC pie to talk
to them about some like,
I don't know what to do.
Like I,
I want to fight.
They offered me to fight Chris Cyborg at one 45 and I was like more of the same.
Yeah.
And I was like,
well,
like hell yeah,
let's take that,
but like,
can you guys at least help me get this shit figured out first,
please.
You know?
And they're like,
sure.
Um,
so Dunkin French,
he's at the,
the,
he's,
so he went to college and,
and was that an oh no,
he was at Notre Dame using this treatment with the doctor.
Um,
Kevin Murphy that runs the mindset.
So,
uh,
he was like,
this guy is doing a lot of things with people as far as brain health.
He's like,
go see them when you get back to San Diego,
it's kind of far from you.
But like give it a shot Kat.
And I called the guy,
I'm on the phone,
super frustrated,
like super like emotional.
I'm like,
I'm,
I'm at my wit's end.
Like I've tried everything I can think of like holistic views,
like chemical views,
this like everything.
I mean,
spending money out of my pocket trying to figure this out cause none of this is
covered by the UFC especially because,
you know,
not something I claimed in a fight.
I mean I fought Amanda and if you don't claim that stuff within the 30 days,
like you're on your own.
And of course my head hurt.
Of course I'm dizzy.
Of course lights are bright,
of course.
I can't think.
Right.
I got in a fist fight,
you know,
and I,
I wasn't doing good in it for awhile,
so I,
I figured,
you know,
but then a month and a half,
two months out when I wasn't better.
It's like,
so even though it clearly came from that fight,
you still don't get covered.
[inaudible] what not one.
It's endocrine stuff too,
you know,
and it's like,
there's very,
there's like
how could they dispute that?
That's where it came from.
Now you go,
hey,
sit down.
I want you to watch something and just play that first round.
Go,
what the fuck do you think happened?
Yeah,
I don't know,
but I mean if you play that video for them,
if any buddy in the insurance business was denying you coverage saying that
didn't happen while you were under the banner of the UFC,
like you're out of your fucking mind.
Watch that video.
What do you think is happening while this fucking assassin is throwing bombs at
your face?
I mean that's it.
That is crazy that that's not covered.
Yeah,
that makes me sick.
Oh,
it's frustrating cause bye bye.
Like literally you look at the papers like it costs me more to fight then.
Then it,
then I made,
let's see,
now it might make sense if it was dealing with a broken hand or a torn ligament
or something like that.
It might make sense in mine,
it does not make any fucking sense.
If you're talking about brain injuries cause anybody who understands how brain
injuries work know that there's,
there's a considerable amount of time after a fight where you still are
suffering from symptoms and you might decide 30 days later,
60 days later,
90 days later you've got to do something about it.
Right.
Well,
I mean now
I know.
Yeah,
no,
I come out of a fight and I'm like,
my pinky hurts,
my elbow hurts,
my hair hurts,
my eyebrow hurts,
like claim all of this,
you know,
because before I was just being tough,
I'm fine.
This is more,
it's so crazy and I didn't like I didn't get it and I didn't know.
And then no,
if they're in the,
if they're in the business of insuring fighters,
they should have a larger window where people can claim head injuries.
Right.
But that's,
I mean that,
that it kind of goes together with like any kind of,
any kind of mental,
anything.
Like any,
you talk about mental illness,
you talk about head injuries,
you talk about Tbi.
It all goes into that stigma of like you can't see it.
So it must not be real,
you know what I mean?
Or,
or whatever.
So it's like that's the head injury business.
I mean basically,
yeah.
The point is to make them drop and be done.
That's what everybody,
I mean it's not,
it's not the worst thing in the world.
The wind with a body kick or an arm bar.
But the reality is what people like is to see head injuries were in the head
injury business.
Right.
You know?
Yeah.
So how long after you starting with this treatment do you start to see results?
So the first,
I would say the first thing I noticed was my motor skills in practice.
So,
you know,
I would go,
do you think your motor skills were impaired?
No,
I,
well I just feel like I had a block.
Like I said,
like it's,
it was comical and I mean,
you can even ask them at alliance and it was funny.
It was funny,
but not to have like,
we're in class,
you know,
we're learning,
I'm watching the coaches,
like they do a drill and they explain it and they look up.
All right,
everybody ready?
Ready,
one,
two,
three go.
And we clap and I have no fucking idea what we're doing.
You know,
like we walk off and I'm like,
like there was even a couple of times where like they clap and there like,
Kat,
what are we doing?
And I'm like,
uh,
three cake.
And they're like,
no,
20 pushups.
And I'm like,
man,
I'm not even like,
I'm not just a bad kid like talking and like,
no,
let's say like I'm in trouble because I don't hear you.
Like I don't,
I can like not lose eye contact the whole time,
like sit here and I'm like focused,
but no,
I'm not retaining it unless though like if it has to be the last thing that they
do,
like we can't talk about shit.
If it's the last thing I see,
I can go do it,
I could go do it.
But if they're like,
all right,
and then they explained some philosophy about it or do some movement or
whatever,
like then I lose what we're doing.
Like my mind would just go right to something else.
Like I had a very hard time concentrating and you know,
it's,
it's crazy because when I got to this facility,
you know,
I didn't know,
I didn't necessarily know what I was walking into,
but they have you do this questionnaire and like on this questionnaire is like
all of these things.
I'm like,
that's part of something like me not being able to focus as part of something my
sleep,
that's part of something,
this startle effect is part of something like me having these like completely
like specific things that are all on this was like damn okay.
Like I didn't even want to see the EEG because I was,
I was scared,
you know,
I was like,
what if you can't fix me?
And now I know all the shit that's wrong with me.
Like that sucks.
But then,
you know,
they show you different egs and they show you the,
they take it every single week and so you actually get to see it and you get to
see the level that you were functioning at,
especially the different parts of your brain.
But then,
and the thing is that's awesome about this is you get to keep the results.
Like unless you go do exactly what you did and go fuck it up again,
like you get to keep it,
it's not like this maintenance package,
which is,
you know,
a problem for these pharmaceutical companies.
There's,
there's,
there's not a whole lot of retention on it because once people get their brains
functioning,
as long as you're not sitting there hitting your head against a wall,
like you get to keep feeling better.
Like these,
these veterans get to go back to,
to combat or whatever it is,
their job is like we fighters get to go back,
football players get to go back.
Like I sat in with the chargers medical staff and talked about our stuff there
as well.
I,
I don't even remember who else there was people from all over the country coming
in asking about this,
you know,
and,
and needing to sit in and,
and they're looking at these egs in particular.
What is it doing?
How is it fixing it?
So one,
um,
I think it,
you know,
there's something with what goes on in your brain with,
with the thyroid stuff,
with the endocrine stuff is like getting your damage to your hip without miss.
Right?
And that's like,
that kind of directs all of the information that goes to your thyroid,
your thyroid,
you know,
then sends out everything to your body.
And there when there's like a disconnect there.
Um,
no,
it was just screws everything up.
And then on top of it,
like now that we're cutting the same way,
we've always had to cut,
but we don't get ivs and we,
I mean,
you,
you cannot 100% rehydrate your brain within 45 or 48 hours.
Like you can get your body decently hydrated,
I believe,
but your brain is just,
it's its own thing,
you know.
And so now we don't have ivs or hydraulic system in our brain is down and now
we're rattling it even more like dehydrated.
I mean,
we're just going to have,
you know,
bigger side effects,
uh,
Tara brains been dehydr with that now.
Um,
the damage that comes to the hippo Thalamus to the pituitary,
to the,
um,
your thyroid,
all of that that goes on there,
that,
that they're,
they're saying that you can,
you can get it firing back at a level that it was before it got hurt.
Like as long as the cells are still alive in it,
they can reenergize those cells.
Now if you have like just a dead part of your brain,
you know,
they're not bringing it back to life,
but they can,
um,
use these magnets to kind of fluff on backup,
give them back their energy,
their,
their life,
and put in a,
put them in back into a functional way that was something similar to you at your
healthiest and,
and make it,
I mean,
not more or less durable just back.
Right.
And when you,
when you were saying motor skills,
like what was wrong?
Cause that's one of the things that they see in fighters that have taken too
many shots.
They start having you,
they analyze fighters.
Gates in one of the things that happens is your legs get closer together.
Your,
your balance is off your,
your steps are shorter,
you don't have that sort of like dynamic fluid motion to your body and you're
having a heart,
a harder time with balance and just motor skill.
Yeah,
totally.
So how I felt before going into there,
it was all I had was a gas pedal.
I was like,
just will,
you know,
and just fuck them.
You know,
just cause I,
I wasn't reading patterns of people anymore.
Like if someone leans this way a little bit,
I'm like,
okay,
I know what you're thinking.
Like if they set this way or that way and even me juking them and like China,
like faint at them.
Like I,
I wasn't,
I couldn't even see the reaction I was making them make,
like I knew what motions in my muscular memory to make them do,
but like I wasn't getting the feedback because it,
it just like wasn't,
so that was one of the first things I noticed was,
you know,
going back into practice and,
and watching people's angles and beating them to it and,
and,
and like remembering.
And I'm like,
damn,
I don't just have to shoot to shoot.
Like I can wait and do it when it's the right time or I can even like,
like take advantage of of the fact that you know,
I'm making them step back or I can flash fire and they're facing and jump on
them at their knee jerk reaction.
You know like these things of like being able to manipulate the situation and
make them adjust to me.
Like I could see that again and I could see you seen before.
Like when I just had go,
all I had was good.
When you didn't see movement,
like say if someone was going to spin and they're like reload it up their hips.
You didn't see that?
No,
it's just hit hit him first.
What were you seeing?
I,
I didn't,
all I saw was get their first,
all I saw was like closed the distance.
Don't get hit in the head.
Like make like get down and get low and just be a linebacker,
you know?
And,
and hit him because I knew I wasn't seeing that stuff in.
The more I tried to see it,
the more I would just sit there and wear it cause I'm like any minute now mean
any minute now I'm going to,
I'm going to catch the pattern,
I'm going to catch the pattern.
And it wasn't popping up.
So then all I had,
if you were just like super light sparring,
just moving around,
you didn't see it?
No,
no,
not really.
No.
Yeah,
that's fucking terrified.
I was like,
yeah,
it was really scary.
And like even I'd even get to like a good position in Jujitsu and I'd be like,
I know I know stuff here.
But she didn't know what to do.
What was it?
I know,
I know stuff,
you know,
but like it wasn't like,
especially with adrenaline firing,
like it wasn't just happening for me.
And so like three,
four weeks into that,
all of a sudden like that fog was starting to go down a bit.
Right.
And like part of it was,
and then,
and then I'm also sleeping.
I have to go before like during like the first week.
Oh yeah.
Cause every fucking person I went to could fix me.
Right.
And you're driving 45 minutes.
Like what the fuck am I doing on it?
Yeah.
In a,
in a,
in a car I leased.
So all those miles that,
you know,
it's like damn.
And um,
it's uh,
it's super frustrating.
Yes.
Everyone can fix me,
everyone can fix me.
And then they don't,
and then my heart's broken again and then I go to the next one and then my
heart's broken again.
And then,
and then the next one said this one,
I'm like,
I'm not even going to tell people about this because I'm sick of fucking hitting
up people and being excited about it and telling them to come with me and then
it doesn't work.
And then I'm that guy again,
you know?
And so going into this and then watching it work and then seeing all the other
people that was working for in there that,
and they were never trying to push me to promote it.
They were like,
just come in,
just get here.
You know,
and if you like it then tow the cars.
The UFC was talking about getting one of the machines at the Pi and they're kind
of going to have me be like a Guinea pig for it.
Ian Mccall went in there too,
but it didn't like he,
he was doing his own kind of other stuff that was making it so it wasn't working
for him,
but like I was all in,
you know,
it's something that was making it so it wasn't working.
I don't think he was coming in often.
Oh,
and,
and the thing is,
is that it does stir shit up.
Right?
So like they,
they,
they mess with your,
the,
the levels.
Because again,
they have to,
like,
if the back of your brain is running at four hertz and,
and,
okay,
eight is technically where like you're sleeping,
you're at rest,
there's part of your brains that could be under your resting hurts.
Right?
Well,
the front of your brain is running at 12 so that's like high anxiety,
but like low energy.
And they can,
they can almost tell you how you've been feeling lately,
which was like,
wow,
nuts to me.
Right.
And you could,
they can tell,
you know,
because of this and this,
that,
that you have some OCD tendencies versus this person constantly feels like they
have no energy in their memory,
isn't working in their emotionally and capable of like being in,
you know,
being a positive force in a relationship right now because they don't have it.
So do,
could reach your brain likes hot.
Damn.
I need to get my fuck.
You should.
It's scary though because when you see that like little like in there,
you're like,
what's that?
But it's for me,
it's,
that's a two hour drive.
Shit.
Yeah,
I know that there,
I don't know if they have anything up here.
I know that they,
they have a bunch all over that is,
let's call it
the website is not coming up,
but this personalized,
repetitive transcranial magnetic stimulation,
a noninvasive therapeutic approach to the treatment of Ptsd and other neuro
neurocognitive disorders.
Uh,
Kevin,
Tim Murphy,
MD,
Vice Chair,
department of radiation and medicine,
applied sciences,
Uc San Diego Director,
Pediatric Radiation Oncology Program,
uh,
Rady children's hospital,
San Diego.
Wow.
Yeah.
So that's where you're going.
And um,
I mean obviously during this whole thing you have to be questioning what you do
for a living.
Oh,
well.
And it's like,
okay,
so they can fix this.
Say they fix it and then I go do it again.
You know,
Cyborg,
right?
I mean,
you were,
you were thinking about fixing it and you,
you were going from one girl who hits like a dude to another girl who might hit
like a bigger dude.
Yeah.
And cyborgs.
Fucking terrifying.
And it's like,
I know healthy at my healthiest,
like no problem.
I believe that,
like,
I believe in myself like that,
right.
I can figure them out,
especially in find a way to not get hit doing it.
Like I didn't get hit in my MMA career,
significant a hit,
not one significant significant hit and tell Amanda.
And then after that I was getting,
if I get lit up right.
And,
and not even that,
even Juliana,
like she kinda opened hand bitch slap me a little bit from the sides,
but I,
and,
but like I can find a way to,
to like still control it enough to be like,
like very effective without taking too much damage.
But like that,
that slow of my,
my motor skills,
my mechanics,
it was,
it was really bothering me.
And that's not how you go fight someone like Cyborg.
You don't go in there with that weight in your pocket.
You know,
it's so important that you're talking about this because this is a,
this is such a factor that we don't see on the outside.
Other people,
you know,
other people.
Then the people that are really close to that you talk to about these things.
Like if we were seeing you fight and you know,
when we see the decline of certain fighters,
you know,
you see certain fighters,
they there in a couple really hard fights and then you see a decline,
like a real obvious decline and their skills and their abilities.
Very,
very rarely are they opening up about what's going on.